BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
Well hello everyone
on the Hangout.
And welcome to the first in our
week long series from the
Creative Sandbox Gallery.
My name is Brian.
I'm here at Google.
And sitting next
to me is Pete.
PETE LEPAGE: Hey.
I'm Pete LePage.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Chrome team.
And I help developers
make cool web stuff.
BRIAN MOROZ: So that's
what we're going
to talk about today.
And today we're going to
be talking about mobile
specifically.
And this whole week we're
going to be highlighting
agencies that have done
spectacular creative work
using some of Google's
products or APIs.
This afternoon we have Beattie
McGuinnes Bungay on the line.
And they are all in London.
So it's very dark out by them.
And we appreciate them
coming on board
this late in the afternoon.
Thanks, guys.
If you guys could give a quick
round of who you are and what
you do at the agency,
then we'll segue
into what you've done.
And we'll take a look at
some of your work.
ARTHUR: Hello.
I'm Arthur.
And I was the creative
tech on the project.
MAX: And I'm Max.
I was the account director
at BMB on Grolsch.
MEL: My name is Mel.
And I am the producer
on Grolsch.
CALUM: And my house is Calum.
I was the interactive designer
on the project.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
Cool.
PETE LEPAGE: So there we are.
And before we segue in, we're
going to talk to these guys
about what they did, how they
did it, who they worked with,
what were the horrible
nightmares they dealt with it,
what were the wonderful
rainbows that
appeared on the horizon.
Let's actually take a look
at a reel of the work.
And we'll jump in after that.
BRIAN MOROZ: Awesome.
MALE SPEAKER: Grolsch is a big
bold beer, looking to deliver
a rich brand experience.
[?
MALE SPEAKER: Yant Van Dig.
This legendary policeman has
never spoken a word.
Local gangs have dubbed
him [? Deres ?]
[? dika ?]
[? daz, ?]
the quiet badger.
Sing, little canary, sing.
MALE SPEAKER:
[? Ke kuriwi wos ?].
MALE SPEAKER: Character speaks
louder than words.
Big, bold Grosch.
MALE SPEAKER: Our TV campaign
was just the beginning.
We invite our intrigued audience
to meet Yant, our big
bold character, online.
MALE SPEAKER: So you've found
Yant, the Netherlands most
notorious police officer.
The man who never speaks,
he is everything.
Text him your name.
And if it sounds familiar,
he'll buy you a beer.
MALE SPEAKER: Yant receives
everyone's text live in the
video, replying in real time.
Mobile technology allows us to
bring our online Yant to life.
And every user has a
unique experience.
Over 2000 uses a day are
texting to see if
Yant's heard of them.
If Yant has heard of them, they
receive a voucher for a
free four pack of Grolsch.
And to make it even easier,
we'll give directions to the
closest place to redeem
the voucher.
Win or lose, people are sharing
their experience and
bringing a whole new audience
to Grolsch.
Try it for yourself
at Grolsch.co.uk.
also
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
Well I thought that was a pretty
cool highlight covering
a lot of neat stuff.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Very, very cool.
Looks like it was a very fun
client for you guys.
I hope so.
And that was a really, really
great use a lot of different
technologies.
So maybe we can kick off and
just go around the table.
And I'm going to ask
the first question.
And this is something that we
think about a lot here is what
led to the idea generation
process.
Were you guys thinking about
Maps technology in the
technology you wanted to harness
and then build a
campaign around that?
Or did you have a campaign
idea and then go seeking
technology that would
fit in there?
What was the process
for all of you?
MAX: Well I think for us very
much actually the campaign
came first.
And the technology kind
of fitted into that.
So Grolsch came to us with a
brief that they wanted to
really relaunch after being
quite quiet for a period.
So we kind of came up with
a campaign about big bold
Grolsch, which is because it has
a sort of slightly bigger
flavor than other beers.
So we wanted to really
highlight
this and hero it actually.
It's got this big flavor.
But it never needs to really
speak about it.
So we came up the campaign of
silent legends, who are
characters with kind
of [INAUDIBLE]
without having to
ever say a word.
So with the creative team, we
came up with sort of TV
campaign which went
out in the UK.
And then from that, we wanted
to then give an experience
that actually got the brand
into people's hands.
So how could we take these big
silent characters and big,
bold Grolsch, and actually give
people experience that
then ended up with them getting
them a beer, which was
then when we brought
the [INAUDIBLE] in.
ARTHUR: I think we worked with
Kate [? Baiten ?] and Joe
[? Brews ?].
And they were the creators
on this.
And they had a really sort of
strong [? leaf ?] of what they
wanted to achieve.
But we worked with them right
from the beginning all the way
through to the end.
And I think that's what
really helped us.
They then led the
creative group--
decided where they wanted
to go, how they
wanted it to work.
But since the beginning, they
kind of got is involved in how
that would filter down from what
Max is saying, which is
brand [? to  have an ?]
experience, which was quite a
tall order at the time.
It felt like quite
a lot to achieve.
But looking back on it,
it worked quite
nicely, that the TV--
that led on to the
interactive.
The interactive then
led to Mobile.
And Mobile led to the kind of
brand to hand experience.
BRIAN MOROZ: Very nice, so
very holistic actually.
So this wasn't something where
it was you guys are just
working on this kind of walled
off digital piece.
This sounds like this really
came across all the different
media types, and that
that was part of the
idea from the start.
Is that accurate?
MAX: Definitely.
And I think it was massively
important, that actually the
digital part of it and the kind
of experience that people
had wasn't just an add on that
came after a few TV ads.
We always wanted a kind
of experience.
And we wanted a reall
interesting digital bit.
And it was absolutely part of
the brief from the beginning.
But we kind of needed to come
up with a campaign, and come
up with what was
[? going to fit it ?]
and then tailor a digital
experience to that.
BRIAN MOROZ: OK.
So that was baked in
from the beginning,
which we love to hear.
And I know that sometimes that's
a challenge, depending
on the client, depending on
the agency, et cetera.
So it's cool to hear that you
guys actually had that from
the get go.
So actually following up on that
note, given that it was
across so many media, and it
was a fairly rich, fairly
complex campaign, who worked
on the project?
How did you guys form the
team within the agency?
How did you decide who was going
to work out what piece?
How did that all
come together?
MAX: Well, we had an account
team who work on
Grolsch all the time.
So it was myself, as the account
director, business
director, and the planner,
[? Jaime ?]
[? Imman ?]--
we took the brief.
And we've kind of worked
on what Grolsch could
[? be with ?] case
and [? Jaime ?].
So it was that core team that
started off the whole
campaign, started off thinking
about kind of
where we take Grolsch.
But we knew very quickly that
we wanted Arthur as creative
technologist, Calum and Mel to
be part of the campaign.
So even as we were kind of
looking at the TV scripts,
even as we were coming up with
these characters, we kept them
very much involved in it.
And we kept them very
much in the loop.
And we were like look, if
there's anything that you
think's interesting around
this, if there are any
interesting technical
innovations, or anything that
you think can kind of help with
this brand experience, we
want to know early.
Because I think the earlier
you get it in to
a client, the better.
And I think through
a [? process ?]
[INAUDIBLE] it was a problem
that actually [INAUDIBLE]
stayed.
And it was probably about a year
and a half in the making
all in all from kind of getting
the brief to actually
getting it out.
And I think that the important
thing was that core team stuck
together throughout.
And actually we worked very
closely with the client, who's
was very good actually, and
very good and kind of
understanding that it's not
always going to be very
straightforward.
And if you're trying to do
something interested, if
you're trying to do something
innovative, there's not always
going to be an example of it to
sort of say, oh, well it'll
be like this.
So actually it really helped
to have the client come in
early, get to know that
team, and get a lot of
trust in that team.
And it meant that actually
moving forward as we came
across different hurtles or
different things that we
needed to do, we had the
client on board very
much from the start.
So that team evolved
and got bigger.
PETE LEPAGE: So I was going to
ask, were you guys, as you
were working through some of
these-- were you building
prototypes for things that you
were like, hey we don't even
know if this is going to work,
or we haven't seen this done
before-- did you build a
prototype to go, OK, here's
what we think it's going
to look like?
So that you'd have something
to show the client and say
hey, this is a prototype.
What do you think of this?
Or where more going for hey,
here are some wire frames, and
this is what we think
it'll look like?
ARTHUR: No.
So I mean I think credit to
Mel for holding it all
together, we didn't
do a prototype.
BRIAN MOROZ: Interesting.
ARTHUR: And one thing
that we do almost
always now is a prototype.
I mean we're working on a
project at the moment where it
literally looks like it's held
together [INAUDIBLE] this.
It's kind of a bit of API
here and then another
bit of API over here.
And it's Times New Roman.
And it all looks a bit sloppy.
But one think I think we've
probably learnt from the
experience is no matter how
rough and ready that process,
it's so important to
get that together.
But we didn't on this one.
We didn't have a prototype.
We had a rough idea of where
we were going with it.
We had--
I think it was five different
[INAUDIBLE]
[? buttons ?] in total
including us.
And we were also rebuilding
the responsive website for
Grolsch at the same time.
So it was lots and lots of
holding bits and bobs that
from a good scope of work we
knew we were going to slot
into place.
The prototype would be one thing
that we've learnt we
could make things easier for
us I think going forward.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
MEL: Yeah.
I think the way we worked
in the end-- we kind of
practically identified
the clear roles and
responsibilities of all the
different partners involved.
Because as Arthur said
there were so many.
In terms of the prototype
though, we did get to a stage
where it wasn't probably til
about three weeks before
launch that we actually had a
fully working model that we
could start to [INAUDIBLE]
and pull apart.
PETE LEPAGE: That's brave.
BRIAN MOROZ: That's
[INAUDIBLE].
MAX: We had quite a
trusting client.
And then having been involved
and knowing the team.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
MAX: And we had a campaign
that we knew was a really
interesting one.
And we just needed to
bring that to life.
So I think bringing the client
in early and then getting
trust of the team actually
really helped with this.
Because then we knew in the
end we'd be fine if
[INAUDIBLE]
deliver it.
But it's just at all the stages
along the way, there's
not always something to see.
ARTHUR: Yeah.
We knew technically that
it was going to work.
We saw pre-written how we
wanted the API to work.
We've got the production part
in the right places.
We've done many practice
[INAUDIBLE] certain areas we
wanted to do.
The thing we didn't do is
a master prototype for
[INAUDIBLE].
It was so difficult with all
the kind of [? bridge ?] in
front of them and
[? think board. ?]
And then [? Mobius SI ?], which
brought them very much
the kind of API that's
we've built.
Now the API was the bit that
we took a lot of scratching
our heads and getting
that right.
Then that was the bit that
we needed to make
sure was rock solid.
Because we just didn't want
any element of the--
if the trip didn't work, it
would be [INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN MOROZ: Right.
But it sounds like you guys were
actually quite confident
of the technology side.
And it sounds like you
also had the team
formed pretty early.
So it sounds like you guys had
the team ready to go working
with the client for a
long period of time.
And you guys felt confident
internally that
we've got this covered.
Except we want to test
a couple of things.
But you pretty much knew
what you were doing.
You didn't have to
build prototypes.
You didn't have to do
a lot of test runs.
Is that accurate?
MEL: Yeah.
I think that's fairly
accurate.
We were confident in the scale
of work that we'd written.
And it was something that
continually evolved.
So we even used kind of the
basic [? group ?] to approach
the production partners.
And when they came back to us
with questions, that's then
more information that--
it helped evolve our scope, and
eventually kind of evolved
into the function spec.
Because it became so detailed.
And that's kind of the main
thing that held our project
together was this one document
that listed exactly how
[? you think ?]
[? they will ?] work.
MAX: I've got to say I found it
quite hard working with so
many production partners.
Because actually there's so many
different people you're
relying on to deliver
the more people you
involve in the team.
So whereas we had a core team.
And it was all sort
of fantastic.
It was always quite hard
when we'd bring
other people into that.
But as Mel said, it's all
about having roles and
responsibilities defined up
front, and then trusting your
partners to deliver.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
Beautiful.
So that's who worked on the
project, and how you formed
the team, which sounded
fairly organic.
It sounds like you guys all knew
exactly where you needed
to be and what you
needed to do.
What did the creative
process look like?
As you guys were developing
this, who was taking leads at
different times?
Where did the idea come from?
Who said I can make
this happen?
Were there particular hang
ups or really tough areas
involving the technology
or even the ideas?
Where there huge
breakthroughs?
Just how did that look from that
year and a half long--
which is a long process?
So how did the creative ideas
come to bear fruit?
MAX: Well just talking about the
very start of the process
before we get into
the technology--
I think it took quite a while
to get to Grolsch and to get
to this campaign of the
silent legends.
So I think that it's something
that once we'd actually come
up with it, it was a
very simple idea.
It was actually a very easy one
to then see how you could
build a campaign through it.
So everything kind of feeds
back into that.
But I think that it took quite a
long time to actually get to
that as a platform
for Grolsch.
And I think that especially in
marketing beer, there's a lot
of very good work out there.
I think that you've got to do
something very good to make
yourself stand out.
And you've got to really do
something very different.
So I think it took a while to
kind of actually define what
the platform should be
and then where we
should go from there.
But that was Kate and Joe in the
creative team, and Jaime
[? McClannah ?] who were the
main leads on that and who
steered the client through a lot
of different routes, a lot
of different potential ways we
could have taken it, and then
come up with a very simple
platform that we could then
build from.
In terms of the technology,
I guess, Arthur, you could
probably shed some
light on that.
ARTHUR: Yeah.
I remember the process
quite clearly.
It went the right
way, I suppose.
Jaime [? Imman ?], who did the
planning, came up with the
approach that he wanted to go
with as far as the brand to
hand experience.
Kate and Joe very much looked
after the creative--
completely made these
characters, envisioned them.
And it's very easy in hindsight
to kind of look back
and go oh, that's what Yent's
going to look like.
Or that's what Herm is
And I still remember getting the
brief, which was we've got
to take a silent character and
make him give beer to the
people that's right, and taking
it all right from that
experience from the TV ad all
the way through to somebody
actually getting the beer.
I think the creative process,
when we first looked at it,
was quite a tricky brief.
I think it's Tess [INAUDIBLE]
that really, really kind of
took it on board with their
[INAUDIBLE] and made it
exactly what we wanted bits to
do and how it would all work.
And that overarching creative
experience that took you all
the way through from one element
right to the end, even
down to figuring out the copy
and the text and which phone
[? you're going to ?]
use, et cetera, et cetera, what
was really, really the
key to getting the whole
experience right.
CALUM: I think from
a [INAUDIBLE]
point of view, there was
a couple of things.
The hangups, someone had said,
mainly or predominantly were
the fact that this had to
be a really famous video
experience.
And I think clients more and
more are pushing for the
[INAUDIBLE]
[? world ?] of HTML5 and what
can be achieved with that.
I think there was a conscious
decision very early on,
working with our production
partner, [INAUDIBLE]
Digital, to go with a
Flash-based execution.
And I think that was a really
important move in the end.
Because it actually created
a really beautiful video
experience.
A breakthrough at the same
time was the actual
interaction once you get the
mobile voucher on your phone.
I think for a while we were
toying with the idea of--
another production partner had
let us know about having bar
codes on your mobile and the
ability to redeem vouchers.
And it's quite a complex voucher
[INAUDIBLE] image
[INAUDIBLE]
[? with Michael ?] and I can.
But what I thought was really
interesting was to kind of
create a level of intuitive
design on top of that that
allows you to actually find the
most local shops based on
your location.
And I think that was a really
nice finishing point to what
was already a really
nice experience.
ARTHUR: We've done this stuff
five to ten years ago of
getting it all the way from TV
to somebody else [INAUDIBLE]
try to redeem it using Maps,
which is probably the funniest
bit of the project to go sit
the whole way through.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
I think that's one of this first
big mobile things that
we've really seen that people
have really been able to play
with, is taking mobile web apps
and mobile websites and
really making them much more
interactive because of the
geolocation stuff--
being able to say, hey,
your user's here.
What can we tell about that?
Or what can we do with that
piece of information?
Whereas you guys have gone
and said, OK, great.
Let's find the nearest store.
Or let's find the nearest
location where
they can go do whatever.
I think we're going to start
to see a lot more of that
stuff coming up in the future
as we get access to more and
more device APIs.
Some of the cool ones that I
think we'll start to see in
the relative near future people
taking advantage are
device orientation and
device motion.
So if you pretend this is my
cell phone, I can pick it up.
And I can move it like this.
And because of the accelerometer
and other
hardware in the machine, I can
make the website or the app
respond to those experiences.
So as we get more and more
access to hardware and the
stuff like that, I think we're
going to see more and more
interesting and exciting
apps and experiences.
MEL: I think another challenge
was this particular campaign.
Because the character of Yant
is quite a simple sort of
storybook character, whereas
with technology, the back end
to it's quite [? companate ?].
So we didn't want to
over-complicate that character
[INAUDIBLE]
even say his mobile phone that
you see your text appear on--
it's still a very basic
mobile phone.
But we had the balance of making
sure it was a kind of
mobile phone that the character
would have.
But at the same time it was a
big enough screen so that you
could read their text on it.
ARTHUR: Yeah.
That was one thing that Kate
and Joe and myself worked
really hard on was making sure
that we got the experience
feel intuitive with your not
having a QR code or doing
something that [INAUDIBLE] the
overall creative experience.
It needed to be something that
tied in with the overall
concepts of these
silent legends.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Yeah.
And I think that's also
important that we're using the
same concepts that our
users are used to.
We want to start getting them
to use new and newer things
all the time.
But we don't want to go hey,
here's this brand new thing
that nobody's ever used before,
nobody's ever touched.
And we're going to ask
you go try it.
Because everybody's going
to be like huh.
I don't know how to use this.
So going go in with the SMS to
send something-- everybody
knows how to send an SMS.
It's super easy.
But then getting a link back--
everybody again knows how to
click on that link.
And it really does get
that, oh, yeah.
This is easy.
I know how to use this.
There's no learning curve.
I can go play with
this right away.
There's no of that drop off that
you get sometimes when
people are like oh.
This was too hard.
CALUM: And just to talk on
that point as well--
I think it's really important
to know which devices you're
designing for too.
So I think from the get go, we
were straight away thinking
about the iOS Android and the
smartphone market and what
people are used to from an
interaction point of view as
well, and how maps are
usually displayed.
And like you said, not straying
too far away from
that and actually building
upon it instead.
PETE LEPAGE: How did you guys
decide what devices you were
going to support?
Was that decided
by the client?
Or was that coming from
what you guys said?
ARTHUR: It was [INAUDIBLE], our
mobile production partner.
We sort of scanned the market.
We knew the audience
[? relatively ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
used.
And from there, we worked with
the client and with the
production partners, and what we
thought was right, the most
[? system ?] support.
And I'm sure you guys know it's
not always the easiest
journey, trying to make a
responsive website or a truly
mobile website on these all
different elements.
So [INAUDIBLE]
to [INAUDIBLE] and
get them right.
MAX: And I think that also came
slightly from earlier on
in the process.
Because we knew that our
audience is very much indexed
on mobile and smartphone.
So actually any sort of
experience that utilizes this
technology is going to do very
well with that audience.
BRIAN MOROZ: Excellent.
And it sounds like you guys were
very confident in your
use of the technology, which
leaves me to ask have you done
work in the mobile, the geomaps
kind of area before?
Was this your first time out?
Be just felt like you
really had it down?
Why did you feel so confident
when you were building this
out that you were like, no.
We can definitely do all this.
We know for a fact it's
going to run smoothly.
ARTHUR: I think that the mobile
geolocation HTML5
device [? on your ?] stuff
[INAUDIBLE] we
felt relatively confident.
Working with Cal, we'd done
quite a lot of responsive
designs before and though
very much from
mobile upwards really.
It's stuff that we've done on
our own site and also for
another couple of clients
that we've worked with.
The bit that was the biggest
kind of leap of faith was the
API we built for the texting
setup and how that would work.
We weren't too worried about
the technology that you're
talking about, about the
APIs with the Maps.
It was more getting our head
around this custom bit of
technology that we'd made and
exactly how that would work.
You guys make it pretty easy
to make the Maps stuff
compatible and work
quite well.
So we weren't too worried about
that part of the project.
BRIAN MOROZ: And while we're on
that note-- because we want
this to be an open
forum, where we
can all be very honest.
What would you have
loved to have seen
from our side of things?
If we could have made the Maps
API or anything that you
worked with on our side,
better, what
would be that request?
Just so that we have a sense
and we can relay that.
CALUM: I guess from an
interaction design point of
view and from the actual
voucher, I don't think it's
necessarily something that we
wanted from you guys, but a
better reliance on native.
So when you're your iOS device,
when you click on--
it was Google Maps--
that would jump out to
your native app.
BRIAN MOROZ: Right,
CALUM: I think the Get Direction
is something that
would be really nice to explore
as a web app more.
I think in this particular
instance, it seemed more
sensible to actually jump
to an [INAUDIBLE] native
Direction app instead.
I know that's something that
is in the pipeline.
It's probably due now.
BRIAN MOROZ: That's great.
And any follow up?
PETE LEPAGE: No.
I think getting those
interactions between native
and mobile and mobile
web are some fairly
big and complex pieces.
And it's certainly something
that from my view, being able
to use those directions within
a mobile app or mobile
website, I hope to see
that come soon.
Because I think there are some
really interesting spaces
where you can play with that.
BRIAN MOROZ: Definitely.
PETE LEPAGE: I did want to throw
out here as well for
people who are watching, if you
want to ask questions of
these guys, you want to ask
questions of us, we just put a
link up on the screen
so that you can
go post your questions.
And towards the last 10 minutes
or so of our session
today, we'll take those
questions and make sure that
these questions get answered by
some of the folks from BMB.
BRIAN MOROZ: Absolutely.
So one other question
for you guys.
Given that you did something
that was very cool, very
innovative, went across lots
of different media types,
involved lots of different
people at your agency, I
imagine you guys learned a lot
of lessons that maybe aren't
obvious when you start
to jump in.
So my question to you then is
what do you recommend to
others who are trying to
innovate in a space like this,
where they're using Mobile.
They're using Maps.
They're trying to connect lots
of different media, lots of
different ad formats together.
What are the things that if you
had an intern and they had
three questions or they wanted
three pieces of advice, what
would you recommend if someone
is trying to do something--
obviously not exactly like
this-- but in this same kind
of realm you guys learned that
maybe others don't know?
MEL: I think [INAUDIBLE]
point of [? view ?]
and the idea that there were
so many different parties
involved, it's just a good idea
to identify who the core
team members are from those
different parties, and working
out ways of having clear lines
of communication so that
everyone's got the
same information.
Just something we use quite
a lot with Google Docs.
Because everyone could access
the same information.
We could do a task list to
assign responsibilities and
keep everyone up to date with
what was going on on that
particular document.
BRIAN MOROZ: So that's just
internally on this team.
Because it is a pretty
complicated cross expertise
team that you guys
are working with.
So just keeping those lines of
communication open so everyone
knows what everyone
else is doing.
MEL: Yep.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great
piece of advice.
CALUM: I think from a design
point of view, it would be
just to keep looking at things
all around you, like from the
latest app to a cool website.
I think it's so important to
just keep up to date with
what's going on in any
way that you can.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
I think to me that is one of
those things that as a web
developer, web designer,
or even a
technologist in general--
staying up to date with the
latest stuff is so important,
looking at some of the cool demo
sites, keeping an eye on
websites like HTML5 Rocks and
other sites where all those
new things start to bubble up
and you can see what people
are doing with them is
really such a great
way to remain connected.
It gives you that idea of hey,
what's going on in this space?
I just was recently working
on a Chrome experiment.
And if you go to
Chromeexperiments.com, it's
another great place.
You can also go to
M.chromeexperiments.com for
the mobile site to see mobile
Chrome experiments.
And a lot of these really show
off things that people either
haven't done before or a very
small new feature that's just
in its infancy, and really how
powerful or how cool it is.
With the Cirque du Soleil Chrome
experiment, we used the
Get User Media API to grab the
user's face and watch how
their head moved throughout
the experience.
Works great on a laptop
or desktop.
But that didn't work
on the mobile site.
So for mobile, we used device
orientation and device motion.
So that is you tip the device,
you can see that going.
So looking at sites like that to
see what's going on, what's
cool, is a really good way to
stay up to date, and as well
as just get some ideas
of stuff that you
can do in the future.
MAX: I think something from my
perspective would probably be
not necessarily through the
technology-- but actually it's
kind of just having one very
simple idea that you can
relate everything back to.
I think us doing this mobile
experience, and us trying to
get beer into people's hands,
there are a lot of points
where it could have become a lot
more complicated, and we
could have chucked different
technologies in and done
different things.
But actually, at the end of
the day, it needs to be a
really simple user experience
and something that is very
easy to do.
And I think at times you can
over complicate things.
And this was a good example of
just keeping it simple, using
technology to its best ability,
and then not trying
to kind of throw other
bits into it.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
And on that note, I assume that
helped you sell it into
the client.
But I guess a kind of a follow
up question is did you guys
encounter any particularly tough
areas with the client?
Or were they just gung-ho
the whole way through?
How did that work out?
And if you had those experiences
where they were
like I don't know if this is
going to be right, how did you
overcome those?
MAX: Yeah.
As with every project, there
are difficult moments with
different parties.
And yeah, we did have difficult
times with the client.
As I've said, he was
involved all along.
And I think that
was brilliant.
Because I think he knew what we
were trying to achieve and
building towards it together.
I think, as a kind of touched
on, the most difficult bit was
not being able to give them an
update every few weeks of this
is where we are.
And look.
You can see how we're
progressing.
It's like they've got to trust
that actually we are getting
on with things even if
they can't see it.
And actually with the user at
the end, it is going to work.
I think one of the most scary
points for me actually was
three weeks before we were
supposed to go live.
And we had our first demo.
And it didn't work at all.
And it was an interesting
[INAUDIBLE].
ARTHUR: [INAUDIBLE]
MAX: But I think the fact that
it had been a long process
meant that we were all kind
of on the same page.
And we were all just like,
OK, it's not working now.
But this is all we need to
do to get it better.
Give us two days.
And then come back.
And I think that yeah,
we managed it.
And it worked out well.
BRIAN MOROZ: Yeah.
It sounds like.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Yeah.
I've got to say that I would
have been petrified three
weeks before going oh, boy.
And then having the demo.
So was it a simple thing
that caused that
first demo to fail?
Or was it something that you
guys had missed caused it?
ARTHUR: It was the
classic gotcha.
It was everything that--
you look everywhere.
And you expect everything else
to be causing the problem.
And it was the one small thing
that you didn't think.
It was actually one
of the APIs.
The API we built used
lots of other APIs.
And you think that
must be robust.
I know that should work.
We've been pinging that.
And that should be working,
no worries.
And it was that element
that was broken.
One of the APIs we had been
using, we just needed to look
at and fix that.
Then we knew what
the problem was.
We got around it.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
BRIAN MOROZ: Yeah, it sounds
like it was an exciting
moment, but one that you guys
got over fairly quickly.
That's the best ending to those
kinds of [INAUDIBLE].
ARTHUR: [INAUDIBLE]
BRIAN MOROZ: So we'll go ahead
and turn in just a moment to
the questions that folks
have been sending in.
But any last piece of advice,
comments, placed you'd love
people to go check out?
Anything you guys would like to
say to the audience before
we jump into their questions?
ARTHUR: I think for me just
while we were waiting just a
kind of really boring element.
But I'm sure there's lots
of devs watching.
I think one thing that I learned
definitely was there
was really [? only ?] key to
make sure everything works
well together is having
[? repo's ?]
a really good system.
We use [INAUDIBLE], which allows
us to deploy to all
different areas.
And that should keep up to date
with the production part
we're working on and seeing
what's going.
And we can share [? rights ?]
and see how everything has
worked together.
And it's the grind behind it.
But it actually makes life
really, really easy when you
come to deploying.
Everything's sorted.
Especially when you've got
somebody that's a production
partner, people are in their
own little word unless
somebody's
[? bringing it together. ?]
We can do preview deploys before
and checking over and
working [INAUDIBLE], so you
can get in big gotchas
[INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So if we pop over
to questions--
Paul B. from London wanted to
know, if you could improve or
change anything, what
would you change if
you could do it again?
ARTHUR: For me, this fell
at the ground of a
lot of bigger ideas.
We had a lot of extension
thoughts we were
really keen to do.
I think we achieved a
lot in this project.
I think we did really,
really well.
But I think if I could approach
it again, there are
lots of extensions that I
definitely would have sneaked
in there to try and make things
work a little harder
and be a little bit more
groundbreaking
in a few key areas.
MAX: A bit for me is actually
we'd originally thought that
we were going to maybe
do this in a pub.
So actually the giveaway
drove to people picking
up cans from a shop.
But there was an opportunity
at one point that we might
have been able to
do it in a pub.
And I think if we'd been able
to drive people to a pub to
get a pint, you could then
do a lot more of
those extension ideas.
Because you've got kind
of a captive audience.
You know they're sitting there,
having their drink.
And you can kind of play
with that a lot more.
So I think that that would've
been a nice extension.
PETE LEPAGE: Neat.
BRIAN MOROZ: Interesting.
OK.
So next question from Bob in
London was having great ideas
in the lab is often easier
than convincing
the client to invest.
How did you manage the client
throughout the conception,
build, and live faces
of this project?
And I think you guys touched
on that a bit already, that
you have a very deep
relationship.
And you brought them
in very early.
Who was your touch point
at the client?
Who were you working
with most closely?
Did you have one contact that
was really your champion?
How did you guys manage that as
this kind of went live over
the course of 18 months or so?
MAX: Yeah.
From the client's side, we had
one touch point who was our
client throughout who was Simon
Pick, who is the brand
manager on Grolsch.
And actually it was very much
we have him as our contact.
He'd understand what we
were trying to do.
And then he would then
go and sell it
throughout the business.
So we'd kind of give him the
tools he needed to bring other
people in and show them
what was going on.
And I think where we managed
him quite well was actually
knowing when to bring other
[? elements ?] of the business
in and when not to.
I think there are times where
you can actually bring people
in unnecessarily
and panic them.
Because you might not
be in the position.
Or you might not have everything
that you need to
convince people that you're
going in the right direction.
And I think that one thing that
was really important was
actually managing the timing
of this process, when we'd
bring key stakeholders in.
So I think it was working
closely with him to then work
with the rest of Molson Coors
and the rest of Grolsch.
BRIAN MOROZ: So knowing when to
bring in the right people,
and when to, let's say, focus
on the smaller number of
people that maybe get it a
little more, and knowing when
to open that door and
close that door
at appropriate times.
That sounds like it was a
key skill in this case.
PETE LEPAGE: Great.
So can you share some of
the engagement results.
Came from Romaine Pier.
If I mispronounce anybody's
name, I apologize.
So what were the engagement
results like?
Or can you share those?
MAX: Yeah.
We absolutely can.
It was actually very impressed
with the engagement.
It was a lot more than we
had kind of hoped for.
Well no.
As much as we'd hoped for.
But a lot more than we'd
expected actually.
In terms of-- it's called-- the
total unique visits, we
had 139,988, which actually--
PETE LEPAGE: Not
to be specific.
BRIAN MOROZ: Not that you
memorized that or anything.
MAX: Over a three month period,
that was very good.
And actually, the Grolsch
website itself went from quite
low down in the teens, in terms
of beer websites, jumped
up to number two just
from this campaign,
which for us was great.
BRIAN MOROZ: That's amazing.
MAX: And it then got a lot data,
a lot of phone numbers.
There were people signing up
to the website and a lot of
things like that.
So the engagement around it
actually was really fantastic.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
Great.
ARTHUR: I think another thing
on that, Max, was that we
managed to get really, really
good dwell time.
I think the dwell time started
around four minutes and ended
up somewhere as an average
of about three.
Not only was the dwell time
really high, but we managed to
accumulate a database of
hopefully really intrigued
consumers that are interested
in taking
it to the next level.
And we've got a few ideas
up our sleeve of where
we'll go with that.
But the plan was to get a core
audience that would keep
really engaged with the brand.
And hopefully their
stats show that we
managed to achieve that.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
BRIAN MOROZ: Cool.
So a question-- and it
sounds like you guys
wanted to do this.
And maybe that'll be a follow
up question from Van Jones.
Do you have a plan for deeper
interaction beyond the initial
chance to win beer or
to go buy the cans.
And it sounds like you guys
wanted to do that.
Do have plans with the client
to actually take this to a
deeper level?
Or is that something that
you guys can develop?
ARTHUR: We're in plans
at the moment.
Obviously, they're
very hush hush.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So no details.
ARTHUR: [INAUDIBLE]
MAX: We've got a decent base.
And as Arthur said,
we've got a lot of
engaged, intrigued people.
And I think that it's absolutely
[INAUDIBLE] that we
want to build on and move on.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So from Peter Thistle
in Vancouver--
has the client shared any
analytic methodology or data
with you reporting from mobile
app how many samples?
We kind of touched on this
in the previous question.
But I'm kind of curious.
I'm going to take it in a little
bit in a different way.
What was the mobile engagement
like, specifically for the
mobile pieces?
ARTHUR: I mean, like Max said,
Grolsch had been not
necessarily [? gomer ?], but not
as strong as it could be
for a while.
There was some [INAUDIBLE]
about the different statistics
or devices that
we needed to approach.
We didn't have a big website
that had been running on
mobile for a long time to figure
out exactly what we
wanted to target.
But I think we all kind of get
a pretty good idea about the
key browsers and platform
that we should target.
And we backed that up with
some knowledge as well of
searching [INAUDIBLE]
before we went ahead.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
So the next question was-- and
we can pause on this one.
Because it sounds like this is
what's in the works for you
guys, is not public yet.
But the question was how did you
think about activating it
in bars around the world?
Since you mentioned oh, we
would've loved to have had
people in the pub.
That would have been
our ideal.
Can you talk about what you
would have done there?
Or is that something that's for
phase two that we'll talk
to you guys in a few
months about?
ARTHUR: We can talk
about it, yeah.
We work with a really great
production [INAUDIBLE]
called Mobius.
And they had some technology up
their sleeve with the stuff
they've done before with Blue
Moon and how basically they've
made this system that would
allow you to redeem a pint in
a bar and then track
it exactly.
There are some of
the extension--
I'm sure people can imagine--
was it allowed real
time stats.
And actually it allowed real
time location even more finite
than you could probably get with
a GPS device, which is
quite interesting.
So some of those, of course,
came from there.
And that was one of the reasons
we were so keen is
[? god, ?] we could do some
interesting stuff like that.
PETE LEPAGE: So I think our next
question, we've kind of
already covered on who came
up with the idea.
So we'll go to the
next question.
Are there further adventures
planned for Yant, re-marketing
to people in some clever way
or anything like that?
And that may have been covered
in what you just--
BRIAN MOROZ: I mean it sounds
like the answer is yes.
But just to confirm, he will
be loose on the world for
months to come?
MAX: Yeah.
He's a great character.
So it would be a shame to not
let him loose on the world
again in some form or another.
BRIAN MOROZ: Excellent
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
ARTHUR: Just to sort of
interject, I think the really
fun part about it is
actually that it
started above the line.
But I think we will continue
with Yant on platforms that
aren't traditional above the
line media, which is what's
quite exciting I think
about the campaign.
Let's say 2013, I think we'll
continue on a certain tangent
that we see it going
at the moment.
BRIAN MOROZ: Yeah.
And it sounds like it's all
blending together very
seamlessly in this very kind
of elegant way across all
these media types, which
everyone says that they want
to do, of course.
But it is a real struggle often
for a lot of reasons
within agencies and with clients
to actually do that.
And it sounds like you guys have
really hit across that
kind of seamless connection
across from television to
digital and everywhere else.
So super cool.
The last question--
and it's a little
bit of a biting question.
And we're all going to be very
open and honest here.
I'm just going to ask
it straight out
from Jim in Lake Tahoe.
And I'll see what you guys say,
which is, looks like your
audience was young single males,
perhaps white males.
Hopefully there's more
to it than that.
So I will let you
respond to Jim.
What was your demo?
How do you guys want
to expand?
What are the demos that
you'd love to reach?
Because that's something
actually we haven't talked
about today.
Who was the audience
specifically?
How did you determine that?
And what would be your
ideal audience?
MAX: The audience for Grolsch
is slightly older.
It's a 25 to 40 really.
And I think it's an audience
that more kind of once you've
had your wild drinking days.
They're more behind you.
And you prefer a quiet, more
premium pint, let's say.
And so that, as I'd sort of
said, they kind of index
against mobile.
And I think that they're a very
interesting audience.
And they're a very kind of
untapped audience I think from
a beer perspective.
So I think they're very much the
sort of audience we'd like
to keep on going with.
But I don't know.
Arthur, or Mel and Cal, if
you've got any other audiences
you'd like to talk to?
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
Jim in Lake Tahoe, if you
have other audiences,
just let them know.
They're happy to reach out
to broader audiences.
And I lied.
Actually Pete, do you want
to read [INAUDIBLE]?
There's one more question
that just popped in.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
So we just had one more question
pop in from Liana
asking how difficult do you
think it will be to keep
selling these kinds of
ideas to your client?
CALUM: To sell this idea?
I think I'd be very difficult
to sell this idea again.
PETE LEPAGE: Touche.
CALUM: I think what's now been
created is this experience
that requires new technology.
So it's a very simple idea.
And I think that won't change
is in the simplicity of it.
I think we all really
appreciate how
important that is.
But as Arthur mentioned before,
I think that's a
really interesting tangent
[? that will head ?] us on.
And also it's a new technology
[INAUDIBLE]
as well.
MAX: I think it's
also really--
I'm sorry, Mel.
MEL: I was just going to say I
think also when you've got
kind of the stats and the
figures, the results of the
campaign, it always makes it
easier then for the client to
trust you to deliver a similar
kind of campaign in another
type of new technology.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, absolutely.
I think that being able
to say, hey, look.
We have 130--
I don't remember the exact
number, but that large number,
and say look, this is what we
did, it becomes easier to sell
new ideas when you can say,
here's some data on something
new we did.
BRIAN MOROZ: Yeah.
But it's key to be able to have
those clients that, first
of all, to be at the agency,
able to explain it in a clear
way and have those clients
that said, yes.
Let's make a little
bit of a leap--
small leap.
We're not going crazy.
And see what happens.
So it sounds like you guys have
a great situation both on
your side and on their side.
ARTHUR: I think to Max's point
I think that Max made earlier
on is if the overarching
creative is right, if it's
right for what they're trying to
achieve, if it's right for
the different mediums, then it's
not such a [INAUDIBLE]
sell.
It's not trying to go ahead
with look, we've got this
interesting technology that's
going to change [INAUDIBLE] if
the creative idea works strong
enough and hopefully with a
bit of back up and prototypes
earlier on will
sort of sell itself.
MAX: And the brief wasn't a
sort of complicated one.
It wasn't a different one.
It was get Grolsch in
the hands of people.
And actually if you can find a
technology that makes that
happen in a better way than has
been done before, then I
think absolutely, ideas
like this will
still sort of fly out.
I think it's just having the
right technology for the right
kind of means.
BRIAN MOROZ: Absolutely.
All right.
Well that about wraps it for the
questions we had for you
guys and the audience questions,
which were very
interesting.
Thanks, folks who are
watching this for
sending in those questions.
Any last comments or topics
that you guys
want to talk about?
Or any last things you'd like
folks to go take a look at?
Now's your chance.
Give us a pitch.
MAX: Go to BMB website.
PETE LEPAGE: What is the
URL for the website?
MAX: BMBagency.com.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
BMBagency.com.
MAX: That's the one.
BRIAN MOROZ: So you can check
out more of their work.
Thank you guys so much.
I know it's like 8 o'clock
in London.
So I hope you enjoy a fine
Grolsch right after
this call is done.
I wish I were right now.
ARTHUR: Sorry.
Last thing.
BRIAN MOROZ: Yeah.
ARTHUR: I just [INAUDIBLE] the
opportunity to say something.
If anybody does want to get into
advertising for London,
there's a really cool thing
opening in the next couple of
weeks, adscheme.bmbagency.com.
Go and check it out.
It's hopefully a fun way
of getting [? formal ?]
advertising.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
Very cool.
And for those of you, if you
happened to come in halfway
through this, this
is all recorded.
And so all of the questions and
answers will be available
in the next couple of days.
And for those of you that want
to follow along the entire
week, tomorrow, same time at
2:30 eastern, we're going to
be talking about the YouTube
API and some uses there.
So guys, thank you so
much, BMB Agency.
It was fantastic
to talk to you.
And if we get further
questions, we will
send them your way.
And thank you so much again.
And have a wonderful evening.
And thanks to everyone who
joined the Hangout.
Hopefully we'll see
you all tomorrow.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Thanks, everybody.
BRIAN MOROZ: Bye bye.
MEL: Bye.
MAX: Bye.